every day people ride buses to places near
and far today we are taking a long bus ride
here in the bus station we must first buy a ticket
Jorge and his father are buying their tickets now
they are just in time for our buses coming
into the station it is big and powerful
mr. Fisher drives our bus he has driven buses
for many years this man tells us when the bus
is ready he doesn't lose the loudspeaker one
five seven thirty coach for Somerville Easton
Harrisburg Bedford Pittsburgh and the West
time to go many people are going with us the
porter puts away our baggage in a space under
the seats mr. Fisher takes George's ticket
inside the passengers are finding their
seats George likes to sit in front so
he can watch the driver before mr. Fisher
starts the bus he closes the door and starts
the motors then he backs the bus away
out of the station we go and on our way
right on time too
mr. Fisher drives carefully in crowded
city streets watching out for cars and
people he switches a signal the signal to warn
drivers behind him that he wants to make a turn
one last look at the tall buildings
as we leave the city behind
soon we are out on the open highway a
highway that is like a river flowing
from city to city cars buses and trucks
roll over it day and night George likes
to see the big trucks like these hauling all
kinds of goods to the factories and stores
but mr. Fisher keeps his eyes on the road
watching the road and the other cars all the time
a traffic light stops us we will lose a
minute or two here and mr. Fisher has to
keep track of the time 9:56 he's still
on schedule but now the stoplight is
changing to go he shifts gears he moves
ahead quickly he still has many miles
of driving to do he knows just how fast
to go on each part of the road to keep
on time and to drive safely now watch
this driver coming out of a side road
mr. Fisher has to look out for all
kinds of careless drivers on the highway
he sees in a big mirror cars coming
from behind here comes a car passed now
here comes another
mr. Fisher always drives safely and never passes
another car when he can't see the road ahead
now we are riding through a fine farm country
look there farm boys and girls wishing the driver
good luck as we roll onward a train is coming
but we'd need not stop for trains our highway
goes under the railroad through this underpass
as our bus goes on the passengers are
having a pleasant time some watch the
scenery others read while others find
napping the most pleasant way to travel
look ahead there's a car stalled on the
highway our driver puts on the brake and
he turns out carefully the driver must
be ready to act quickly at last we're
coming into another city the bus turns into a
station much like the one from which we started
here's some of the passengers
are leaving this this is the
end of the trip for mr. Fisher to
and so George tells him goodbye
a new driver mr. Thompson will
take us on from here mr. Fisher
turns over the tickets everything
in order mr. Thompson is ready to
go to work soon we are leaving the
city on the second part of our trip
we cross a broad beautiful river out on
the road mr. Thompson settles to his word
in a little while we reached the
entrance to a great superhighway
on this wide superhighway mr. Thompson can drive
more safely and more easily and passengers can
ride more comfortably two cars that cross this
highway have to use bridges overhead like this one
why'd separate lanes and well-built
curves mean faster safer driving
we are nearing a mountain ridge it is a high wall
across our path but we plunge into this tunnel and
right through the mountain out on the other side
and down the mountainside into the valley beyond
now we come to a place where the
bus stops to give us a short rest
a place to stretch our legs and to eat lunch
a nice lunch room by the side of the highway
while Jorge and his father and the other
passengers have lunch mr. Thompson makes sure
the tires have plenty of air he looks at the big
motor to see that it has plenty of water and oil
now he can go to lunch too
in a little while we are on
our way again the passengers settle
down for the last hours of the trip
mile after mile goes by as mr. Thompson drives on
now we cross a valley a valley of steel mills and
factories we're nearing the end of our long ride
mr. Thompson's worked for the day is almost
over the passengers get ready to leave the
bus hats and coats go on journeys and mr.
Thompson has driven another long bus trip
safely and on-time tomorrow he will drive
back over the same Road now it's goodbye to
mr. Thompson and goodbye to George let's hope
we'll take a bus trip together again very soon